want to talk about the smelliest man on
the planet let's talk about the
smelliest man on the planet who was
sitting next to us at the at the game
Claudia has this thing where we go to
games the guy next to her oh man
spreading like sitting on my lap always
puts his leg like in her chair because
she is I sat with my legs crossed that
doesn't mean that like the space that
I'm not using then belongs to you like
my negative space is not your positive
space [__] back the [__] off he was so
smelly he was really smelly and this is
just like a PSA like if you don't wear
deodorant don't go out in public it was
so rancid like smelly man smelly armpit
hot t-shirt
boiling hot and by the way so they kept
giving you know it's a playoff game so
it's high stakes they gave everyone
towels and you're supposed to like you
know you're supposed to whip around the
towel like you know to cause drama in
the stadium so I'm under this man's Wing
because I'm short and he's whipping his
[__] towel and spreading his seed all
over the stadium and it was not right
heinous